[Musique]
devenir accueillant familial est un vrai
engagement c'est en ce sens que le
Conseil départemental organise avec les
services concernés des réunions
d'information en direction des personnes
qui souhaitent obtenir un agrément
aujourd'hui l'assistante sociale et la
psychologue du conseil départemental se
retrouve à la Maison Départementale de
l'Est à
saint-endré notre responsable du service
c'est Madame paludin joseine et puis
vous avez des administratives qui
s'occupent de vos dossiers notamment
madame je notamment madame Bertil qui va
s'occuper de tout ce qui est votre
dossier en fait he gestion de dossier si
vous manque des documents et CER je suis
Madame bass basque mariisie je suis de
sain- rose je suis famille d'accueil
depuis ben bientôt 5 ans puisque je suis
là en renouvellement et j'ai un
accueilli
euh une
personne
handicapé je dis ça je dirais mental
comment on dit ça comme ça je suis agréé
pour les personnes âgé et agé handicapé
des réunions d'information importantes
pour bien comprendre ce métier et
également se renseigner de nouveau pour
continuer à le
pratiquer Maria alis est accueillante
familiale depuis maintenant 5 ans à
travers
l'équipe les actions de santé la end à
moi à travailler
hein
accagn très bien accompagné accompagne
lche pas comme ça vous dit ben voilà les
ACC familiale famille
d'accueil non on les accompagn les
convoquer à des à des réunions à des
groupes de paroles on a tout un équipe
qui travaille parce que si l'équipe
d'Action de santé de saint-o travaill
moi d'un pour apprendre à moi travailler
parce que par rapport d'expérience au
départ point d'expérience déb fait oui
on a fait papier adratif pourêre famille
d'accueil point d'expérience c'est à
travers B qu' apprend à travailler
comment faire comment travailler pour
George et Odette c'est une première
George s'est occupé de son père
maintenant que les enfants sont partis
son épous Louis souhaite accueillir des
personnes âgées chez eux pour
reconstruire une famille la de
travailler travaill dans le bâtiment
tout ça après avoir travailler dans le
commerce la personne écoute on trouve
pas travail ben pourquoi pas essayer de
faire ça bon comme on a un petit peu
d'expérience mais a fait quand même 3
ans enfin dans a 13 ans mon papa habité
avec nous comme il est décédé il y a 10
ans déjà et pendant 3 ans mon malupe de
luit pendant ben à faire ses soins quoi
mais après il avait le droit à la PA
tout ça donc et ben voilà maintenant ben
veut continuer comme ça parce que me
trouve pas de travail donc pourquoi pas
essayer de faire ça à la maison voilà
avec ma femme effectivement on a eu
quelqu'un d'hicapé chez nous donc ça ne
poserait pas de problème de de
dans ce sensl ben parce que les
personnes âgées déjà une et puis est
toute seule une grande maison là est là
puis il faudrait avoir de la vue dans la
maison et puis n dem de réfle une
première étape est franchie par tous les
candidats qui disent oui à la poursuite
de leur candidature désormais ils
doivent remplir un dossier fournir des
documents donc là je vais vous expliquer
un petit peu le dossier d'agrément vous
avez demande initiale donc soit vous le
faites de façon individuelle c'est à
votre nom à vous soit vous le faites en
couple donc en couple il faudra cocher
couple les travailleurs sociaux ils font
le logement l'évaluation sociale avec la
personne et la famille et l'évaluation
des remplaçants he c'està-dire qu'on va
aussi rencontrer la personne qui sera
sur votre dossier voilà c'est dans le
même temps dans la même on va trois
rendez-vous à peu près voilà voilà et en
compl enfin en complément il y a aussi
une évaluation psychologique donc qui
est faite par la psychologue de de votre
secteur donc moi j'interviens sur le
secteur Nord-Est et Sylvie du bourjal
sur le secteur Ouest voir bientôt à la
venir Sud les qualités requises pour ce
métier relèvent de qualité humaniste
euh qui sont nécessaires et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il y a une évaluation
psychologique de ces candidats pour
porter un aspect clinique un regard
clinique sur leur candidature
et
évaluer une indication ou une
contreindication à l'agrément une fois
toutes ces démarches effectuées le
Conseil départemental a 4 mois pour
rendre sa décision au terme de cette
évaluation là on se doit de de rendre
nous un écrit qu'on verra après en
commission départementale alors c'est
une commission technique départementale
d'agrément qui est
don bon il y a des représentant de
membres d'association personnes âgées
personnes handicapées vous avez le
responsable du service Accueil famili
l'équipe
évaluation le médecin des actions de
santé bon du territoire concerné et des
représentant du conseil départemental en
fait on va présenter le dossier de la
personne avec ses motivations si on on
voit qu'il a toutes les conditions qui
sont réunies sociales psychologique et
matériel après la Commission les membres
de de de la commission vont donner un
avis alors ça peut être un avis
favorable ou défavorable cet avis là va
remonter au niveau de la présidente du
conseil départemental et elle donnera la
décision de l'agrément l'agrément est
accordé pour 5 ans et les familles
d'accueil font régulièrement l'objet de
contrôle pour 2015 564 agréments ont été
accordés avec un record pour le sud qui
affiche 328 accueillants familiaux dans
le Nord on en compte 55 dans l'Est 95 et
dans l'Ouest 86 en fait il y a six
conditions à remplir euh donc le
travailleur social il va aller à
domicile pour vérifier si toutes les les
conditions sont sont retenues la
première condition il faut justifier de
conditions d'accueil qui permet à la
personne de se sentir en sécurité le
bien-être physique et moral la deuxième
condition il faut que le logement déjà
la chambre qui va être qui va être
bénéficié pour pour l'accueilli il faut
que ça fasse 9 m² pour une personne
seule et 16 m² pour un couple on a une
troisième condition qui qu'il faut
réunir il faut avoir ce qu'on appelle
nous une continuité d'accueil
c'est-à-dire que lorsque
l'accueillant je sais pas aller en congé
ou à l'extérieur il faut que la personne
ait une présence à domicile donc ça la
4eme condition il faut que le il faut
que la personne elle ait tout ce qui est
Attestation d'assurance responsabilité
civile au niveau de l'habitation et pour
soi-même après vous avez une 5è
condition c'est qu'il faut accepter
qu'il y a un suivi social et
médico-social voilà il y a une
obligation de formation continue et euh
et initial he l'initial c'est pour
reprendre le métier d'accueillant
familial avec toutes les le règlement et
les formations continu c'est sur
différents thèmes en fait
[Musique]
voilà